這裡是 AI 101，全網最幽默的 AI 新聞
美國原本放行輝達的H200
讓它有條件賣到中國
沒想到真正把H200卡住的，反而是北京
北京門一關，華為就趁這個空檔
靠昇騰晶片搶下更多需求
可是華為自己也卡住了：產能不足
高頻寬記憶體也短缺
回頭看美國當初怎麼想：
與其完全禁止中國拿到高階晶片
不如有限度開門
讓中國企業繼續用美國的硬體和軟體
把中國留在美國生態裡
可是這道小門有代價
2026年1月起
H200要先送進美國做第三方檢測
再出口中國進美國就得課25%關稅
成本轉嫁不出去，只能輝達自己吞
就算美國放行，晶片還是很難進去
2025年12月，川普宣布放行隔年2月起
美國核發少量出貨許可
但北京仍限制銷售5月路透社說
一顆都還沒交付到了7月
出貨少到被形容為微不足道
政策這樣反覆，輝達產線也跟著轉
3月初媒體報導，輝達暫停H200
把台積電產能轉去做Vera Rubin
結果不到2週，中國訂單出現，產線又重啟
就算真的到貨，也不一定進得了大陸
8月英國金融時報引述消息人士說
字節跳動和騰訊各收到大約1萬顆H200
但北京希望多數晶片留在大陸以外
像是放在香港
這些卡關，最後都反映在輝達財報上
2027財年第二季
資料中心營收890億美元
運往中國的資料中心Hopper產品不到其中1%
下一季財測
乾脆完全沒算中國資料中心運算收入
輝達運往中國的資料中心Hopper產品
占該季資料中心營收不到1%
華為就站出來說它贏了
Eric Xu表示，照華為掌握的數據
昇騰在中國市占已經超越輝達
不過這是華為自己說的
樣本和底層數據都沒公布
外部的估算呢？
券商Bernstein預測，到2026年底
輝達在中國AI晶片市場可能掉到約8%
華為則升到約5成
那華為到底靠什麼搶到客戶？
Eric Xu承認，晶片可能沒那麼先進
但供應可預期，可能比紙面效能更重要
華為不一定最快
卻把供應確定性當成賣點
但不會斷貨，不代表供得出來
Eric Xu也承認
華為產能連中國國內需求都不夠
高頻寬記憶體又短缺
一款昇騰晶片從年初大約6萬人民幣
漲到超過8萬
產能已經不夠，偏偏又有一個大計畫
媒體報導
DeepSeek計畫部署至少16萬顆昇騰950DT
華為2026年卻可能只產20萬到30萬顆
若數字都成立，會吃掉一半到8成
不過這是匿名消息，兩家都沒證實
比較確定的變化在軟體
9月30日
DeepSeek在GitHub公開了支援昇騰的開源工具
中國的AI推論正往華為搬
但大型模型的預訓練，還沒全面離開輝達
所以這場競爭沒有簡單的贏家
勝負要看3件事：
香港的H200能不能進大陸、
華為能不能擴大晶片和記憶體供應
還有中國一線AI公司
會不會連預訓練也搬到昇騰